okay
let's give it another go i'm on
chess.com trying to beat
the computer
all right
well let's
i feel that the best way to try and beat
this
is
by playing solid so a6 i've seen it play
that before
and it's not good i don't think
but that doesn't mean that i'm going to
have an easier time it really doesn't
so let me just get my bishop outside of
my pawn chain my idea is eventually
going to be to try and get in c4 and
i will be able to manage that
and if knight f6 i think i just want to
stop it from
picking up
any
imbalance i don't want to allow it to
get my
bishop with that knight h5 here now this
c form that i want to get in to open up
the c file
eventually for my rook
i'm going to have some issue with knight
b4 i believe so maybe i should invest a
tempo
invest a move on a3 it continues to play
fast as usual
how it's uh programmed and well let's
let's take so this was also my bad
bishop
pawn or queen you could actually see
both there
pawn takes you know it's it's doubled
temporarily but
this pawn will be exchanged so i'm happy
with how things have turned out so far
and let's get my rook here i'm
anticipating the file well it will be
opened up
but i'm not sure i want to do it just
yet so
hmm
do i take
first yeah i'm going to take let me just
try and make sure i have a clear
structure this is dropping upon the
knight takes and then bishop takes so
can also consider just capturing again
i'm gonna do that
if the queen takes i could play here
interesting okay hang out for a second
bishop here queen check queen d2 queen
takes queen king takes
i runs into this move i'm not really a
big fan of that
um
but then again you know what i could do
bishop c4 queen here queen to d2 queen
takes queen knight takes
and then if e5
i could take it
what are my other moves if i go rook c5
there could always be queen takes and i
don't know if i don't i don't know if i
like that particular
structural change
um
so you have to be concerned about this
e5 move
maybe it's best that i get the queens
off
all right we're gonna have that check
i'm pretty sure so i'm and i'm pretty
sure i need to block like this
yeah
all right well let's go for it
queen takes oh
whoa computer's afraid of the queen
trade right i think i do well to just
get out of
this pin this seems like a very good
square for my queen
until that moves played
structural damage
on its way or do i just back up and keep
everything super solid
i'm gonna do that i don't i don't want
any
structural imbalance let me get castled
i'm feeling comfortable
okay i think just rook here
just get activated i was also
considering queen here but
all right now now here and then queen
here
okay okay b4
b4 and then queen c5 ah that move huh
what about just pawn push
i guess i don't like having a pawn fixed
on a light square
but uh i'm gonna have to deal with that
aren't we
queen here
for a queen trade
my king could uh look at my time not
much time so
um
let me defend this pawn
knight's gonna play here i imagine
queen trade i guess
i need to remove that knight now how do
i recapture
i want to keep this file open half
opened
and now
here
pressure on that pawn
what's wrong with that
bishop here
if pawn push i'm not getting trapped or
anything i think i want to just attack
that knight can i get rid of that knight
i'm missing oh what a
what a bum
let's try um
if i go here i'm getting hit with the
fork
however bishop here
knight here i could take this pawn no
not really because knight takes rook and
then they're on my bishop
um
let's come all the way back i guess
uh
you gonna go back repetition
oh my goodness are we gonna have
repetition
oh i'm gonna take it my chicken or what
i am a chicken
let's take the draw
let's go back here
ah let's i didn't do this the last time
i
i went uh and played it
but a6 yeah i don't i don't know about
the a6 move
i'm a chicken i'll take the draw though
i'll take the draw
h3
yeah there's
keep in mind there's this other capture
here
just to compete on the c file but
i don't know this knight c6 move it's
really not the
the best move but i didn't know how to
really take advantage of it
should i have played on
probably
but uh
i just wanted to keep it very simple
this is what i was fearful of
yeah i was fearful of after queen d2
to take
queen takes queen
and then this e5 push i don't know
why that wasn't uh
i don't know why that wasn't played
um
let's try one more actually
can't end on the
repetition
that's no fun
all right let's try this let's let's try
another one here one more
win lose or draw
okay
let's go here let's let's make sure i
could maintain something in the center
here and d5 is going to be it
all right they're going with the double
fee and keto
and similar to what i did
before i want to make sure there's not
going to be that sort of imbalance maybe
i should have done that even one move
sooner
all right let's get my knight here i
don't know where he wants to go just yet
here here's something i can say i want
to be cautious about playing bishop d6
because if e4 is played successfully
i'll have to worry about a fork
not too great so let's let's go here the
knight's in a pin and i'm also maybe
getting ready to exchange dark square
bishops
it might not be a bad idea a3 is maybe a
move but it's not being played
um this is a certain pawn break i could
be going forward with but
i think this bishop is better placed
than my own or is it should i really
consider damaging the structure like
this
i don't know about that giving up the
bishop and then he's he's going to get
here later on with like a4 bishop a3 so
well let's let's get let's get a trade
in there
all right so here's where we stand oh
queen trade i love it
i love the queen trades
alright so how do we play this end game
a5 let's go here to start i should
probably get castle too
soon
very soon um
yep let's get castled i was considering
here but i think there's still too many
pieces on the board to
to be in the center like that
but rook here
prepping this advance i could get it in
still ah this bishop is
is gonna
give me a headache though isn't he
yeah this bishop is kind my bishop's
kind of stuck
let's go here maybe i could like do a
little a little dance here
i'm looking dance just a little bit here
bishop here here but it just drops back
and then h3
i'm not really sure what i want to do
let's come over here
since they're devoting their rooks to
the center
this is my only pawn break but i don't
know how great it is
um
i'm not sure what i'm supposed to be
doing here
a knight would be really good here maybe
i could do that
maybe i could and maybe i should
if i do this this is opening up the file
but maybe i could get some pressure
here let's try this
double up and then push yeah
now after the no hang on
let me push now
i'm gonna have to give up my bishop for
the night i have this square
get out of there i can't deal with you
not at all
all right this can't be bad there's no
way this could be bad
no way it could be bad
um
another repetition
no my knight needs to um
he whoa i didn't think that move was
possible look at this rook though
oh is he getting active
i don't know that i like that maybe i
should give this rook a kick get out of
this fifth rank before i take here and
you have any thoughts of taking here
all right let's take
oh what a tricky move but what about
this
what about this wow look at my options
king up knight here pawn push my first
three choices i don't know if i have any
more
i don't want to take here
go here i have a bunch of exchanges
let's come over now i'm
threatening to take
oh they're giving that up are they
um i really like to get rid of their
knight it's way too tricky
uh they're too good with their knight
there
uh
oh what about
takes
uh let's try this let's get rid of their
bishop
and
more trades let's do this just to keep
the knight out of this square we're
gonna have more trades aren't we
we're gonna have more trades okay get
out of pins and stuff
three to two majority look at this
i want to get rid of their knight i got
to take here
and
let's keep i want to play like rook here
rook here i'm night here
so i i could have something to bite at
here i need a better king position
this can't be good for them
king position and then rook here put
pressure on this pawn
uh maybe i should have done that one
move sooner
let's try this
oh
there's that move
okay of course
i need to get this pawn back i need to
keep giving checks
get back over here i need to get this
pawn back
oh man i take if i do that okay well i
have a i could get a pass pawn
what happens if my king just comes up
here i don't know
let's get this kite let's get this pawn
rolling
i keep getting him rolling
uh now i could come over here though
try uh he's gonna come over there can i
draw this look at my time
oh
not liking that
um yeah i'm not really liking this at
all
yeah they're gonna get that pawn aren't
they
oh i'm close to getting mated
aren't i
king here takes takes and then i'll be
able to get this pawn
i'm missing something
maybe
they really take
you give a check i could kick their
they'll give a check first that's an
important move
it's a very important move
oh
oh they're going to get that pawn
yeah this is big trouble for me i don't
have any time either
they're thrown in time burners
where'd they learn that
this is this is the last this is the
last uh i gotta get back here no here
i'm cut off that's the problem one of
the problems
uh cut off
and it doesn't matter this is a one king
and upon end game
i thought i could have done better than
end game not the case
ah let's go back
quickly
yeah it was
it was kind of even i don't know if it
should have loud like um
this is a
a very common move as soon as queen e7
is played oops right here
to play a3
but uh
yeah i'm able to get the dark square
bishops off and it's pretty even
i could have done better than end game
though
somewhere around here
important point in the game i don't see
anything wrong with giving that rook a
kick
and then taking
this was my other thought d3
hmm
i'm not sure
or each ring
i mean it's going to be scooped back up
the knight could always come back here
maybe there's even something better it
could be doing but uh
yeah we just getting to these trades
here i really maybe i was too
anxious to get rid of the knights at the
cost of my pawn structure
that could be another thing
i played this move maybe too quick
and i don't know why i thought that
after this pawn takes wasn't uh
wasn't a good reply probably just this
keep pressure on the pawn and then
improve my king position is something
i could have
done better
with
i
guess yeah
if i had to do it over i would probably
come here immediately and then get my
king position and then look for this
sort of stuff
but
as it happened here
i gave that up and thought i would be
able to keep
i thought i was able to keep like either
giving check
and then get this palm with the rook but
what i was forgetting is that if i could
take here i was thinking i could get
this guy next
but this pawn always gets captured like
this position right here
i take here
takes there
then it has two pass pods they're split
but it's going to be able to do
something with that
all right well can't
oh i don't know what just happened there
that was weird
okay anyhow um like i said win loser
draw with that last one this is uh not
gonna play it uh anymore at least uh for
this time
but uh as always i hope you got
something out of this video take care
bye
you